hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Plato's Republic book 10 contains a very
interesting discussion bearing upon who
actually has knowledge of the objects
that we want to discuss compare judge
and perhaps create and use in this
discussion Plato is once again
reinforcing the point that imitative
artists by this he means in particular
the poets but this would also include
painters sculptors those who are engaged
in any of the things that we call the
fine arts don't really know much about
what it is that they are depicting so
that they are not good judges to be
relied upon in questions about what is
for example good or bad right or wrong
beautiful or or ugly in a a real respect
now Plato's argument the way that he's
presenting it would seem to be open to
some counter objections that might arise
from Plato's own other examples that he
uses and we'll come to that in a bit but
first let's get the basic idea down
Plato tells us that we have three people
involved in this sort of relation we
have the person who is a producer of an
object in this case he uses the example
of somebody making equipment for a horse
like a bridle and a bit you know the the
reins we could get a saddle maker we
could have anything that we like person
who you know shoes the horse and then we
have the user the person who actually
rides the horse and presumably has a
basis of experience then the third
person involved in this is the artist
who is depicting this what what does
Plato have in mind here so think about
Homer the great poet
epic poet who wrote the Iliad and the
Odyssey and if you've read either of
those books
think about the many passages where
Homer seems to be showing a kind of
expertise in all sorts of matters
ranging from generalship to our you know
craft production to medicine to
divination all of these Plato says could
be looked at as involving a producer who
is doing something some sort of effect
or object that is supposed to be
produced and then the person who it's
supposed to in some way benefit or be
used by so if we think about you know
divination Homer you know tells us well
you need to mix together you know this
amount of blood and this amount of
barley male and this and have these
incantations and then you'll be able to
talk to dead people right Homer is the
the artist and presumably there were in
fact people who were carrying that sort
of thing out and in this case the judge
or the user would be the person who
commissioned them to do that debt job
Plato uses the example of the equipment
maker the horse person and the artist
depicting it or he has another great
example that fits really well here
flutes right you have the person who
makes flutes you have the actual flute
player who plays the flute who uses the
object created and then you have the
artist depicting how a flute ought to be
made or how it ought to be played or you
know whatever it else it is that they're
doing perhaps it's a painting of a guy
playing the flute a flute might mean
something like this as well or perhaps
it's Homer telling us about you know the
this beautiful flute playing done over
here carried out by using this wonderful
flute that was made in this this or that
manner right so this is what Plato has
in mind what he tells us is that there
is some knowledge possessed by each of
these people
but not all of that knowledge is
relevant to the object itself what does
the producer actually know the producer
knows how to produce that object they
have a craft knowledge what we would
call techne right so a flute maker
actually knows how to bore out wood or
if I guess if the flute is made of metal
as our flutes are now today they know
how to cast it they know which ways the
little keys ought to be or you know if
we're thinking about a recorder right
you know how how far the hole should be
spaced apart from each other all that
sort of business the user Plato says
actually possesses more knowledge than
the producer how so they know how to use
that thing they know how to make use of
it and they know what ought to be the
case in order for that used to be
successful and Plato here says that they
know that from experience so they can
judge the object so if the flute player
sends over a flute the user can take a
look at it and say if that one's not
going to be very good
let's send that one back or they can
pick it up and say well feels right
start playing it and they're like ah you
know this one is sharp send it back
similarly with the horseman right the
equipment maker
knows how to take the leather and the
metal and turn it into the the equipment
that you know controls the horse we
could say the same thing about a saddle
they know how to take the leather and do
something with that we're talking about
you know shoes know how to put the shoes
on the create the shoes for the horse
how to put them on them but the user is
the one who is the judge of whether the
job ultimately is done to standards or
not and so they inform the producer the
flute maker says hey I need flutes that
can play a little bit louder I'm having
trouble you know getting my sound heard
over these these drummers they're making
too much noise over here figure out a
way to make the
louder and then the flute maker says
okay interesting problem what can I do
with that so that's all at this level
right producer object user what about
the mimetic artist the imitative artist
the one who depicts the object perhaps
even depicts its use do they have any
knowledge Plato says no they do not have
knowledge about what counts as good
production or what counts as good use
they might happen to stumble upon it but
there's nothing that guarantees that
they know what the hell they're talking
about or depicting and we can see this
all the time think about not only you
know Homer and talking about how this is
done this is done this is done think
about fiction in our own time where you
read it and you're like this person
clearly doesn't know anything about what
it's like to be on a factory floor today
or another great example you know think
about reading some sort of romantic or
erotic literature and be you know be
having the reaction of well clearly this
person doesn't actually know how human
bodies come together in sexual ways to
enjoy themselves
you know we might say the same thing
about some artists some some visual
artists a great another great example of
that you know they say I'm a sexual
thing think about love scenes in movies
right completely unrealistic or even
worse in television because they have to
meet certain standards in order to be
able to be on the air
now you know those are those are kind of
silly examples but you get the point the
artist there's no guarantee that the
artist knows anything remotely about
what they're depicting they do have a
certain kind of knowledge though the
painter knows how to mix colors and how
to depict the appearances of things the
writer knows how to talk about stuff you
might think about
advertising as an art in this respect
trying to talk up the the benefits of
the object in ways that may not actually
reflect anything real anything true
they're just all about talking about
appearances so Plato thinks that this is
a good reason to think that the artist
is yeah once again you know several
removes from the real things the artist
is not giving us sort of an unvarnished
access to reality but is actually
concealing reality from us we need to go
to the equipment makers and the users to
find out what is actually the case let's
think a little bit more about this
argument that Plato gives and and look
at the scope that he says he talks about
the excellence the beauty the rightness
of every implement every object that we
create like rains or a vase or you know
a camera every living thing and every
action he says do not the excellence the
beauty the rightness of every implement
living thing in action refers solely to
the use for which each is made or by
nature adapted so presumably you know if
you think about the human body and the
human mind we are also of that sort but
we could talk about animals plants we
could talk about the wind we could talk
about all sorts of other phenomena each
of these has some sort of use and we
would want to look at who is the actual
user now in some cases we can't say that
we have a producer not in the same
respect as art you know technical
production you can say of course that
you are a product of your mother and
father getting together and having sex
but that's not the same thing as
producing a camera or producing a
chalkboard isn't or even producing a
lecture like this
so this is a very wide scope and we
don't always have a producer so that's a
bit of an issue for this but we might
also think about some arts where Plato
thinks that these people really do
possess knowledge like medicine for
example and is it really the case that
the producer has in a certain respect
less knowledge or less capacity for
judgment about how things ought to be
then the end user the patient perhaps
this argument doesn't work quite so well
for that so this might show us one of
the limitations of this passage this
idea we could still very important
distinction to make here we could say
that in some cases this doesn't hold up
this higher level of producer object and
user with the user being the person who
informs the producer since you know for
example in medicine it's not always a
good idea to have the patients telling
the doctors what to do although you do
need patient input right but we can say
that the artist the one who is depicting
it the person say writing for a
television show about doctors is
probably not as good of a judge as an
actual patient or you know a real doctor
a great example of this would be the
actor who was in commercials I think it
was for perhaps Aniston it was for some
sort of painkiller and he would say I'm
not a doctor but I play a doctor on TV
and I recommend this this particular
pain medicine for you now at best that
person is an imitative artist there's
more than one imitative artist there
there's the actor the director the
person taking the the video the writer
and all of that but none of them
necessarily know anything about medicine
or the object of it which is healing
and if they have been users they've been
users you know just like the rest of us
and that may not necessarily translate
into them having any genuine knowledge
so there are some limitations to this
set of concepts and distinctions but
none of them actually go against Plato's
notion that the imitative artist is
still several more removes from reality
than our the producer and the user of
whatever it is that is under
consideration
you